welcome to this video coverage for round
five of them I looked it up the supreme
masters 2013 or the Norway super
tournament Norway chest super tournament
around five and the standings before
round five are really curious because
kayaking is leading with four out of
four won his first four games so on of
course first place at the moment and
he's in pursuit by la camara with plus
one I was also show at the end of the
last video and if like Ramona was on
fifty percent on plus one sorry if i
confuse you I didn't I didn't look it up
last video so nechama rides on plus one
before the round and then we've got a
couple of players with fifty percent
amongst them the magnus carlsen who drew
his first four games and this round
round five sees the game kayaking
against Carlton so look forward to that
one okay and as before I'm going to go
through all five games with various
different um yeah depth because there
are some some of them are not dead
training really let's start with this
villa against Anand and lost the the
round before against Nakamura this
complicated ruler pet swam on both sides
actually had chances to do something
yeah in this game we see Arnold playing
the night off one of his main defenses
against 1.e4 is also playing e5 and the
coke on but the night' offices main
weapon at the moment and still a place
h3 this curious little move fat has been
played lot by by Fisher and the six
is the ideas in factor to really expand
with g4 and quite often it the
transposes to some other setups for
example if like those g6 white can
switch back to the dragon type play not
be there three of course but h 3's are
useful moving in many lines yeah
unplayed 'if I've this is in fact not
the most common move because for years
it was considered to be slightly
inaccurate night de tu and now the
reason why it was considered to be a not
so accurate asst that for years they
played the normal-looking with Bishop e7
which is answered by white sad eng form
and then he plays Bishop g2 93 castles
and maybe after thorough preparation in
F form white spends only one temple for
the g4 move it is done in one move and
this is one funny point about this line
because there's also this variation but
look at this something like this one
should be six probably not the most
precise and G form because white wants
this square for the night so white
basically gets the temple compared to
this variation this is why the response
be five on h3 always was considered
slightly dubious but now where she
played h5 and this is a new idea the
early age five and not new in this game
but in general it's a new idea against
this this line to play quick h5 to
prevent and block G form and this in
fact seems to be perfectly playable for
black the h5 idea is some also see
nowadays against various setups with f3
wear white plans to play G for black
just play
h5 to prevent this quite a hyper modern
approach with age five but it has got
clear clear purpose damn Bishop g5 white
uses this slightly we can square and
maybe he wants to exchange this Bishop
to increase the control of the d5 square
a problem is that in this setup if you
look at this all this is very very
normal that in the set up on you might
argue okay I white still has this a
weakness on five this is true d 5 is
some this typical whole of the night 0
for specially called variations but um
white has got very limited idea see how
to use the square look at the nights
this night only to especially is very
bad peace cannot go anywhere and you can
only improve it with very elaborate
maneuvers let's say something like this
or you can go here and then play naughty
233 let's get rid of a couple of those
arrows night here and here but not one
problem is that 95 isn't even working
because of night takes but um white
basically has two nights for one
weakness and this really doesn't give
white much the sword structure the h5
ideas really a really interesting um
yeah here I don't had various
possibilities he could play basically
any move that that doesn't blunder
material whoopsie aid or something he
chose a different idea b5 very
aggressive but it works out very nicely
yeah white is grabbing otherwise it's
really questionable if black isn't even
know better black is able to play before
you will have quite some play against
them against the football and well white
white took and now queen bee ages what's
the point if white now
it's just like this you grab me two and
half the better structure even like has
got just one pawn island against two
with the sea to being particularly weak
so you cannot just go back if white
plays a move like this there's this gap
fork like response so what is why it's
going to do it he basically needs to
play something like this it took and
covered and now black has a good to
reply Quincy eight this attacks the h3
porn with this battery and also sets up
the Bishop c4 threat which is really
annoying really annoying move and yeah
you can try to find something for white
here it is some it is not easy at or two
to play something decent here you can
give up h3 but it's not really helping
much something like this like also has
got this H for ideas all the time it's
it's no problem at all in the game
sweetie I decided to to just wrap the
game up with 96 and this leads to
further simplification black doesn't
need to to grab on aged three years but
it's just better to take here because
it's a double attack and now basically
everything got got exchanged and they
agree to draw a couple of moves later so
I quite a quite a dull game but it's it
may be a good thing too if you play the
night off and you need to move against
h3 h3 it's relatively popular simply
because the main line doesn't give white
don't give white anything else as well
so they try to do that now where you
feel play black on the night off this is
so this is a good idea with be five and
and age 52 to counter that okay um next
game let's check Nakamura against T'Pol
off Nakamura playing before and we got
an ID off here again we should be 26 we
should be three others so I'm already
slightly curious why the normally
castles here but Nakamura has a
different idea in mind he plays with
gphone interesting but it's playing g4
before Black has castled they also add
yes to play g4 after black handsome
Castle short here the power of
immediately goes for central counter
play with d5 this is some the kind of
move fridge which really yes stops
whites attacking ideas and immediately
but it's a bit slow of course and we see
that after those captures IAM between
takes whichever three that white has
some development advantage but it's not
all not all positive we've got the g
four moves its looks like bit of a
random movement not really connected to
the rest of the position on Adam let get
some playing Queen a5 and this irritates
wide really how do you want to continue
the problem is do you want to Casa long
do you want to cancel short probably you
need to Casa long and if you go for
example you want to let's say you want
to avoid Queen d2 the Queen trade and
you want to play here for example then
you still cannot cancel short let's say
for example cancels go in here and let's
say 97 just for example you still cannot
do this because a 2 hangs so it's
basically forcing a queen trade
and now I think it's a matter of of the
curacy from blacks point of view to
completely equalize that white is I mean
maybe white should preserve a little
something but it's not easy at all I
mean the little something is based on
the the development and we see that with
95 like one a tempo on the bishop and it
was chased away from the strong long
diagonal I think after that there's
really nothing I mean it would be I
would be surprised if you are able to
find something substantial in this
position I read somewhere that Nakamura
was really am criticizing himself
harshly for playing a three and that
would throw obey any any ideas to play
for for something that this is possible
but to be honest I focus on on the other
games today and didn't look so much at
this maybe was some very accurate play
um white could preserve something but
it's it's still hard for me to imagine
if night a seven is a good move the
intention is Bishop c6 exchanged the
strong bishop and if those bishops come
off it is very very Jewish so wyd
prevented bishop c6 well not technically
but no one is going to give up his
Bishop for nothing so 194 and now I
might be five this is good forcing the
trade or allowing 96 next move so we had
this episode 26 not 96 of course and now
Bishop t6 everything gets exchanged off
and after some further moves they they
played on a bit but there's nothing
really going on yeah it's all equal all
the time
and here on a draw was agreed so I don't
think that there was anything
particularly exciting happening in this
game I'm not saying there wasn't some
way to improve from whites play but it
wasn't so apparent to me how to how to
do it and as mentioned I invested them
more analysis time in the other games
okay let's switch to him to read job of
a row me on this was in hack them and
even less exciting affair yep so we had
a sloth defense and a job of place at e3
line answered by Bishop f5 which is the
most solid response yeah now white
normally online tanto en top-level chess
responds with the 93 e six and nine th
form which is sometimes called the slow
slow um dad is in fact indeed a rather
slow approach to the game very often it
happens that this kind of structure
comes up and white enjoys the bishop
pair and this is the yeah the course
that white is some well this is the
reason why white is claiming he sees is
better Black is very solid but this is
normally what why discern is playing in
the service line Roger before ever took
on d5 and played queen bee three at
first it might look quite curious why
would you exchange on d5 right after you
have blocked in your own bishop in fact
this line isn't so stupid I have played
it myself as white the main idea is that
of course this Bishop f5 move weekend to
the b7 porn and black now needs to spend
a move to kappa b seven
the best movers Quincy seven were to
Java from what aronian a plate and then
we have push up t to e6 check 96 cancels
you should t6 and Bishop b4 yeah this is
the big idea behind wide set up you are
deliberately play three with the the bed
bishop on c1 but you managed due to this
due to this pin to get rid of it this
way and what you're trying to achieve as
the following you see that in the game
actually takes and now takes on d6 what
you want to achieve is exactly this
structure with the backward see porn the
only problem is that it's not leading to
something i have really analyzed this
for for for a long time years ago trying
to figure out if there's some way to
play so precisely that you can really am
long-term pressurize the porn but it's
not working this is just one of the
lines that are not working for white
queen c3 and now I'm Aronian place the
the best move Queen B form this is at
least this is the most direct to move
for two to equalize it's not the only
one you can also go 97 this is also
equal but this is the the quickest one
actually at the text oops it detects the
beep on and so wyd needs to take now the
beep on the setting and if you try to
protect it with 93 there's a five coming
and a four with this weakness on v2 like
will win this poem so you have no choice
v3 must be played and then the accurate
move 97 this prevents the 95 jump and
actually asks right okay are you going
to do with your nights the night is not
going to be fine as mentioned and the d2
light is also not a great piece
Black's ideas a5 a4 and this will
completely em yeah kill any any sort of
play so why does is trying to expand
here on the on the queenside but of
course now black has a good and simple
of course move to equalize completely
this is a five of course it's it's good
and good move but it's also the only
move if black is now for whatever reason
I'm not paying attention and play
something like f6 for example then night
be three prevents a five and you will
suffer long-term on c6 it's quite funny
that that some some computer engines
still think that this is probably equal
I mean it's difficult probably to break
down a computer in this position but um
I'm a human player would never ever
allow this if he has got the chance to
to play a five okay the computer also
plays a five it's just a matter of
assessment i would say that i'm not
playing a five is really horrendous
error okay a five this was played and
now you can argue house white even going
to equalize do these points a week but
there's a tactical idea might be three
takes takes takes takes and what now
black can grab on before the issue is if
you do that that's the the funny move 95
and now we see that blacks back rank is
the problem black now must move the
night there's no other way you cannot
take it it's checkmate and so you must
for some reason i cannot take the smooth
bag let me check this yeah cam becca
into a pause the recording for a moment
i i'm not sure what what the computer
was doing it was simply not accepting
any interesting
okay so route before the problem was
nice to see five and you cannot take
because you cages are made so black must
retreat probably here and then the move
like 95 is it still a draw would be one
it's the raw black could could do that
actually I thought maybe 95 but we
cannot of course play okay edge because
it's a self-made but yeah okay it looks
slightly ugly for blanket or took place
it here it's there maybe g4 is that an
idea just to yeah it's still it's still
a mate yeah don't know maybe black could
even take it but I wouldn't I wouldn't
do it myself I mean it's very simple to
just play up six and attack the spawn
white has no move anyway he can only
play this and this happened in the game
black captures and now I was slightly
surprised that a job will played details
g5 I certainly would have played PTX you
fight but ok it's a draw in any case if
you take him black will probably play
this and here you could argue that the
structure famous white but probably
there's not much happening it's very
difficult to do anything King will be
only seven and probably a bishop on be
five or so and from that it covers this
is six square it's it's nothing going on
yeah the game it took with with the deep
own and had this idea attacking those
two but a couple of months later okay
here draw was agreed yeah black as a
pawn up but it's it's completely
impossible to to do anything anything
active him just completely dead draw
Rowan if you look at the clock played
this very quickly and the job will spend
lots of time not quite sure maybe he
tried to surprise him with this
really half-forgotten line but it's
really not too difficult for black to
equalize and we see that aronian managed
a particular effortlessly okay now
switch to the game hummel against one
how the local diet the second local guy
hammer now with the draw out of the
first couple rounds first round he first
rounds and let's see how it's doing
against this one how we got this final
line with three f3 which is really
fashionable nowadays it's really a good
choice if you played the zimage anyway
against the Kings in yet and so you have
those those interesting lines against
the goon trod one however plate just
Bishop g7 and here in fact we see that
it's not necessarily a direct
transposition to the Kings Indian
because white here uses some the
opportunity to play an early night to e2
and maybe night e to see three the
problem is that of course the same
issues f3 set up um yeah really doesn't
do much much positive thanks to the AG
one night there's also a very famous
quote by am yeah American Russian Grand
Master GU felt who said that the others
image is a nice line against the Kings
Indian but ask the night g1 was it think
so what it thinks about it of course the
night would like to go to a three but
that's the porn okay so what am I is
doing he's just putting the night on e
to and after the young also slightly
funky move asics very early in a 6cm
like the didn't cancel he played matty
233 so this gives on a completely unique
flavor to to the setup and the good
thing is you quickly get your night out
of them his urges do one place you
prepare castling and the night those two
nights are not so badly plays sometimes
you can set up in this fashion ID to or
sometimes even 93 and we see that here
one how prepares the b5 advance and Tom
are we near uses those nights night a 3
B 5 and night c2 back so white has only
played pong moves and a couple of light
moves and like didn't cancel but
expanded on the queenside really bit of
a funny opening but ok this kind of
setup with a 6b five c6 is some is known
for a long time it is playable against
various Kings Indian setups and all this
is quite quite normal why took on b5 by
the way because he doesn't want to allow
like to take on C for a possible idea
just to show when I'm when I'm talking
about black might take here because this
is an idea winning a tempo and this kind
of setup versus quite nice for for black
also this move is interesting or in this
concrete position even this hard to tell
which is best yet but like s is good
because f3 is really ugly if you open up
the position III is particularly weak so
this taking and d5 was one idea so this
is why um hammer took on d5 in fact this
game developed rather normally they are
similar lights of position types arising
in the zimage and sometimes also in the
classical variation um however the game
was getting really extremely complicated
and this is because now when how plate
Bishop to b5 which is some Jam not
not an uncommon no maneuver in this type
of position it it controls f4 so black
might jump to f4 with the night with the
bishop and adjust an activation also
covering the d6 ball and now I'm hammer
plate the g3 very directly going for F 4
and now in a couple of moves this
relatively slow maneuvering game turns
completely crazy now black has more than
one way to deal with with this he can
for example um play yeah that's not a
move you like to make it something like
this this kind of stuff and why does
certainly slightly better but black is
fairly solid it's it's it stays with a
normal kind of positions but what now
happens is is very very sharp while how
plays f6 and this is has a simple idea
g5 trapping the bishop this Bishop is of
course err on the side of the board so
it is a valid tactical idea but it leads
to a complete mess responses fo of
course and this one have countered with
the with the very sharp move g5 in fact
I think you you needed to do that um
taking on c3 I think is just not right
white will also play ac4 and maybe open
up the position even for his vision so
this was necessary I mean it's a and not
sure if it is really good but it is what
what he had planned obviously and now
we've got a serious the curious sequence
of captures took the bishop black took
the bishop took on d6
and took on g three white by the way
also could have considered to take on f6
witches may be stronger but this is some
the end the computer wants to play
something like this and gives wider an
edge but Edison says such a crazy
position out of the blue devil king side
detonated and um yeah I can I i
understand that white maybe is better
he's got on gays quicker in mobilizing
his false and sculptor whoops already
centralized he's got this kind of
maneuver which can be very strong and
dumb it's not so easy to play for black
may be taking on f6 was was stronger a
dumb we see that Bob's takes on d6 we
see that also both players um yeah white
captured on g3 it's hard to to not do
that we see that hammer was down to
seven minutes and run how to 20 and the
position now is really a murderous
playgroup g7 you see that White's King
is completely open and blacks King isn't
exactly great as well and I did some
analysis on on this with the help of the
engine but to be honest I'm not really
sure what's going on it's it's extremely
extremely complicated and playing this
with limited time over the borders
certainly certainly is super difficult
he played 92 you must cover g3 instance
make sense and after all this like drop
back at first you might think okay black
ass probably great but there's this 93
idea with night f5 being a useful a post
and
in fact them this should be a should be
all right for white turns extremely we
had now Queen to a five plate look at
it's basically blitz game now neither to
h5 and Knight to f5 yeah and now this
position is the first critical one in
fact the next couple of moves contain
extremely many mistakes but this is free
minute check crazy clear three-minute
chest now and this position is just
murderous at first you would think that
in this pollution I shouldn't like win
somehow I mean queen and rook are on the
king it is wide open I certainly am what
we are to do to get mated here in fact
this doesn't seem to be the case but
it's um it's looking very dangerous um
okay what what black played is rook to
g5 which team seems to be a mistake at
least objectively but as I mentioned
it's its murderous to play black a good
play in fact a queen age to King here
and then root g5 this seems to be M yeah
maybe about equal the computer
assessment but it's very very hard to to
UM you have to comment on that because
it's it's basically in eight minutes
there eight moves and four minutes in
this position it's basically like a log
rolling dice you have no idea what's
what's going to happen on their whites
whites king is on the run but he's got
the deep on it's a very weak bishop it's
hard to tell the computer says is equal
but you could probably analyze this for
hours which I am which I won't do if you
are interested in supplee you have fun
to look at this end
some more detail in the game you played
a rock g5 immediately and this white
that could answer with the rookie 3
which is a helpful defensive news check
check and now Knight to f4 the inator f4
seems to be a mistake but it's as
mentioned a murderous position it seems
that good for white now is rock d to
note the queen is attack and it doesn't
have a check this is interesting here
and then look f3 the sequence of moves
israelian it's really difficult to to
see and that leads to to a winning
position for white what is black
supposed to do now the the night ears
detect and if it for instance give this
check you just move the king there's not
nothing happening and at the end now
there's the pawn and like he's got no no
good move here he's really tied up but
who is going to calculate this with four
minutes on the clock it's it's it's not
not possible he played the movie 7 which
is the much more human roof and was down
low on one minute after d7 black could
have drawn the game with 92 and this is
not even so difficult but to see that it
is a draw but it is very much possible
that black was trying for win here or
something because look at this position
white skin is it's really close it's
just some checks on pin and and it's
made but on the other hand of course
this deep hole is not bad as well yeah
192 was the draw I can show what I can
show why knigu and white captures ooh
takes he can try that but
ok that's the this made idea and how are
you going to to prevent that now yeah ok
to run out of checks now and now black
is winning even or or gucci want there
are 22 threats in fact after group takes
the g to the draw can be reached with
your g3 check booboo cakes just
deflecting is okay and then you can even
take and this is in fact a perpetual on
white skin it's it's really funny that
after night g two white can even
consider to move the king this looks
really crazy but you can do that the
king is not so bad on e3 this is in fact
the best try for whites to continue the
game you're still threatening this and
black don't have a check okay you can
check on g1 but it's not it's not
helping so much look at this okay maybe
maybe it's still it wrong yeah white
cannot play for one okay this is in fact
the easiest draw a draw that that i had
seen was on where is it rooty 8ly can
also just block that and now continue it
it ends in a draw as well so night g2
was the move that here was securing a
draw he played rugby eight and this in
fact should lose but ok i know it's
still a drop sorry i have my notes here
but they're there
so on full of lines that you can hardly
a hottie follow I mean if you if you
have some time on your hands you can
really try to analyze this game it's a
nice exercising in tactical calculation
because it's it's such a messy position
playing that was nothing on the clock is
probably a murderous in fact the clock
here says hammer on one second yeah I'm
not sure it probably was not that
dramatic but maybe it was close to that
it's possible um here um look g one was
played and this in fact loses 92 would
still have been a draw it's not so clear
cut as before but it seems that this
this should probably still be a draw at
the end it's not as that clear-cut it's
not a little bit tricky for black but it
probably is still the best way to to go
he played as mentioned look to g1 also
very normal move setting up additional
threats um the fun thing is um yeah how
about played the the human the lawn in
this rock g3 getting rid of the material
and playing that position in fact it
seems that the very cold-blooded Queen
f6 would have won but this is just a
theoretical possibility you will never
play that with 20 seconds on the clock
yeah just have a look at me okay like
dodging bullets and here in fact as the
rookies on g1 that's not even a single
check like must do this now okay and
this is in fact a very easy win because
on white is got to be should h3 coming
covering in the d7 on so any any endgame
is just dead lost with Bishop 83
keeping this yeah so the cool move Queen
f6 what is one but okay hama play this
and this still preserves wide some
advantage it's not that bad move
especially considering the time you see
that now the clock is has minus 18
seconds okay this is a typical relay
problem you only see that they were very
download time so exchanged yeah Queen
takes was also possible giving white
some edge queen age for King f2 and the
King f7 em it's it's really difficult
here nitrous on what better intending 95
to attack d7 and this seems like the
best way for black to fight but it feels
unfair to to point out the possible
improvements that that a computer can
can show you but this is just an
insanely complicated position to play
yeah king of 74 night here and Queenie
f3 enter after Queen a three here
there's one move left that also one how
needs to make and here miss missed a
good opportunity it seems that the c5
here was strong this is in fact I think
a move that you you can find because it
addresses the broad issue of the bad
bishop on b7 it's now on an active
bishop again and this seems to be much
stronger than the movie played he played
this also understandable attacking the
Queen but after Queen to f5 um it's not
a parent hope like now should try to
save the game I think it's actually lost
now Queen right to g5 probably lost the
game at the end now you're sitting there
with this bad bishop and it's not coming
into play again night back it's our time
to finally move in
and now this Bishop gets activated okay
a queen trade and Bishop f5 and now this
is basically one end game with this
great ponent bad Bishop here there's a
funny tactical possibility pointed out
by the engine you can actually promote
here this wins this vision and this oops
is answered by them and the straps the
light funny enough you go here you win
it and if you go here you win it as well
so d8 Queen just lowered the King on the
default so that you can pin it quite
funny move but ok what hammer he played
is completely winning as well he just
exchanged all this and now the tactical
idea group takes h7 because of this
thread blacks rook needs to go to d8 his
aunt possess and now black doesn't have
a movies basically in soups one why just
improves and okay if he takes then you
get this dead end game with the extra
points and this very bad structure
Bishop en the spawns wide world probably
focus on that and combined with the info
on win all those pawns yeah good win for
hammer but it was a terribly complicated
game and just a matter of good nerves
and technical alertness and in time
scramble you cannot really say okay they
played so many mistakes it's not it's
not the human assessment you will you're
bound to make mistakes and from a
computer point of view in those kind of
positions try play that over the board
against GM and you will
lose every game probably because they
will just trick you all the time with
technical stuff okay so now I switch to
them to the main game basically of this
round the last opportunity for the world
number one Magnus Carlsen to try to stop
coyoacan from running away with the
tournament basically with father Floyd
it has already happened I mean so hard
to stop him even in case if we counted
wins and he's got blank so not easy have
a look kayaking as usual playing before
and Carson chooses g5 going for the main
line basically the classical we will
pass and kayaking case rookie one so not
d3 this end time marshal news which is
popular nowadays but rupee one this is
so mostly due to the fact that Carson is
not playing the marshal in general and
in addition the marshal is of course if
you if you want to win as black and
Carson wants to win now he must win this
game I'm to stay in the tournament
basically the marshal is of course a
terrible choice if you were what to win
with black because white can draw yeah
however he wants it there are so many
forced lines that lead to some endgame
the porn app where white draws so and I
don't think maybe kayaking would have
simply done this in case of the marshal
bean plate why not make a drop and
secure your nice first place okay so as
expected Carson doesn't even try for the
marshal and we get the absolute main
line of the classical close to Runa pest
causal place night be eight of the dryer
variation yeah funny-looking move
retreating the night but like I'm with
this move corrects one
in a deficit of next structure in the
ROI and some other be 45 structures this
is the bad placement of the knight on c6
because it is limited by those pawns are
those porn on c3 it doesn't really have
something to attack so this night has
mainly one row when it blocks the sea
porn the seaport really wants to
participate in the game mostly on c5
sometimes on c6 so like just get
retreats it makes this move from
possible or c6 of you if you want and
you can reroute it to this happen where
is not in the way of any pieces with
light a5 is the old chick or in line
Black is trying for something similar
but sometimes the night is misplaced
yeah this is the variation I am playing
for black ok 98 but not because i think
the briars worse or something is just i
learned this night a five years ago and
um i am for years now i want to learn
the briar I can play it it's not like I
have no idea but it's not my mainland my
main opening saudi 497 currently five
Bishop to d7 rookie aid we see that this
some corrective move Knight be a to
disable investing too loose has led to
quite a quite an ammonia set up this
Bishop is nicely placed that put some
pressure on you for the night is not in
the way of anything and black has the
opportunity to use the c forum in the
fight for the center a for playing
against this pawn bishop f8 so the
typical regrouping quite often blackwell
even fianchetto with the bishop and then
see how to continue here there are many
ways to to play for white and you need
to be a bit cautious of course after
Bishop evade you cannot easily play the
typical room maneuver like this because
after 84 before as hanging there's
pressure on the spawn also a benefit of
this night regrouping 27th that you
really put some pressure on you for
white a normally place we had a move
played in the game Bishop d3 or removes
the the beep on and in some way this is
others ok but Bishop b3 is played this
attacks the b5 point and provokes c6 so
black only plays c6e are not see five
lucky often does in the briar but ok c 6
is not a big deal black and at any point
later play this anyway if the the moment
is right and sometimes it's even an idea
to play d 5 s black completely
detonating the center and exchanging of
the whole central pawns yeah ok
continued Quincy to rook c8 opposing the
Queen a bit took and before a very
normal structure Quincy seven should be
20 Katie I'm fighting form for the fr
would be one white wants to keep pieces
on the ball and play in the center not
to be six yeah this observes the c-4
point and here we get to the first
important transformation of this game we
have from a position where um yeah it
first of all it is a rather typical
position that occurs quite often in the
in the Briar variation and as you see it
k it can for one on site only be
slightly better for white because you
have quite similar structure on the
queenside but white has this dominating
position in the center we've got this
ideal porn center
against those cones but on the other
hand it's not easy at all for what to
make any sort of from progress in this
position how are you going to ever
change the structure for example you can
never really am hoping i can realize
okay no it's gone how do you ever change
the structure if you exchange on e5 you
simply created complete symmetry on
porn-wise it's completely symmetrical
yep surface on move h6 but in the center
it's a symmetry and then how are you
going to change the structure in terms
of of porns the only other way to use
pauses f4 which is completely
unrealistic and how you're going to play
a four-year ever never never possible so
there's only one one other idea left and
this is what kayaking played see form
it's a it's a good move that's a good
move but if they only move to make any
sort of progress like took and Bishop
tanks and now we see that this Bishop is
is nicely placed here on c4 in fact I
think that writer enjoys a slight
advantage not not a spectacular thing
but white is certainly a slightly better
the interestings also note that Carlton
is really playing for William it's not
like when he wants to win the game but
he doesn't play any crazy stuff because
if you place let's say the Latvian
gambit kayaking will only laugh and win
laughs not not love and win and you need
to be a be solid anyway and try to keep
pieces on the board getting a
complicated game but he's not the kind
of person who plays some crazy opening
to try to win
age six and now kayaking took on e5
which is fine it's a simple and good
move there were alternatives one
interesting is to retreat this bishop
and ask like okay what are you going to
do now this can lead to quite funny
variations I want to show one of them
like this and you will first thing okay
there's lots of pressure on the pond
yeah in fact it is but there's also lots
of pressure on the kingside night 19 0 +
f3 this is so just an interesting line
due to look at what happens if black
retreats now that's the cute move Knight
takes h6 based on those two bishops this
is made next move and that's it quite
nice in fact after f3a blacks best move
is there the insane going to be six
intending c4 check but this after all is
not playable because on King h2 and
white still enjoy some a substantial
advantage and it just for argument's
sake this variation showing it because I
Final Four did say it skewed there
should be three sm an interesting way to
keep the tension for a moment this also
one is a bit sharper d takes d5 as plate
is good however he just took and played
the strong simple move Bishop c3 and now
we are in a position where it is
symmetrical here but look at those
pieces white is got to active bishops
while black has got the bed bishop on b7
and the simple ideas
to be two and put pressure on the five
porn and this is really tricky already
for black Carlton tries to help on his
position by exchanging and advancing the
spawn yeah here I think kayaking mister
mister chance to get a green iam yeah a
good position which in addition you will
never ever lose I mean just a completely
risk-free thing he can do he could just
take him and after the recapture it
doesn't really matter how black
recaptures let's say here player play
this move and when I five it's it's not
the kind of cover it it's simply gone
now d 7 is punished by Rupert e7 frankly
speaking I'm not quite sure what them
black should do this for example is
quite similar still cannot cover it you
can only aside between various Alliance
where you are porn down and it's just a
porn forum for nothing the only a
technical problem is it is four against
three so any kind of endgame rook
endgame is probably drawn but it is a
very good and safe choice for from kayak
inland considering the the tournament
situation I'm surprised that he didn't
go for that however queen bee to was not
bad for white white maintains some some
edge of even here he simply attacking it
immediately and now c4 gets inserted
this is the the difference black keeps
the sea pond we should do a for loop
here and 95 so he wins upon after all
the only difference is it is much more
complicated
it we should be seven attacking this
phone and here and kayaking I think
makes a slight mistake here we treat the
bishop it seems that Bishop b5 was
somewhat better activating the bishop
and attacking see form and this seems to
also preserve I'm quite a substantial
and it's already a pawn and and ce4 is
dropping this is not even a great place
for a group so after Bishop c4 it is
immediately attacked this seems very
strong he played the move Bishop to see
to just covering everything I think ok
I've got an extra porn and what what
exactly are you doing here it's
understandable that's an understandable
move that but the other one is simply
stronger rookie 8 yeah threatening to
take so white needs react now and ki can
place this correctly it needs to do and
for now until he does so covering the
night and now Bishop to b6 and now where
we got to get to a crisis in this game
I'm really surprised that they had so
much time left yeah yeah what is some
council actually am threatening here he
is threatening something the idea is to
play nine to h5 attacking the spawn and
it cannot easily be covered with g3
because this is a week square as well it
seems that here ok I can no need to play
there's more than one move you can also
play g3 even but also look III was an
idea um and this can get completely
crazy it just have a look like an even
play this insane looking move and it
gets a get so messy that you can hear
you can analyze this for for quite a
long time in fact I had some some crazy
computer lights that ended in in a very
dry end game
but of course there's there's so many
possible ways to play here that you can
cannot really assess it i mean we
compute the things that white is still a
bit a bit better but how very hard to
play all this in the game you played he
played king to h2 which it first looks a
bit shaky but his attention was night
age five no g3 f6 and 90 m and
everything's safe isn't it in fact this
is not the case Calvin can sacrifice on
f4 and he did yeah okay All Blacks
pieces are active now and yeah the king
is slightly slightly drawing here also
note that those bishops are nice but
they block the clear they block the
Queen the Queen has somehow trapped by
their own bishops cannot help in the
second rank now therefore is a strong
move white now only has got one move to
to defend rook takes these six and he
played that this here okay just for
example it's really hopeless Queens III
as the big point I would look and this
is completely over this is deadly Bishop
takes rook cakes of course not Bishop
takes and what a bishop yeah over it's
probably a false medium so white
couldn't really capture on there for ya
black of course takes the night and not
to look if you take him white is winning
again so just here and yeah how to
assess the snow this rookie exchanged
blacks got got one pawn back and the
result is he just won the F porn and
this means look at this whites got them
quite a bad porn structure and he's got
problems on this pawn bishop to deform
and in fact I think um get some finally
loses really the game for kayaking and
it's really amazing how quickly this
went down hello King edge to was was a
mistake you can say okay allowed this
the sacrifice but this in fact seems to
lose I mean he's under big pressure
anyway but the problem of this we should
be formal versus that it leaves the rook
unprotected and cousin immediately spot
the charms and place at five this is
very strong and also he has a trademark
of a really good player to spot this
very very strong technical news and the
problem is some what you needed to see
is white can play me five here that's
not like banks winning a bone or
something what are you playing now this
was played in the game and what I wanted
to emphasize is that oops sorry that you
really must play this move if you play a
slow move which I can easily see myself
making because I cannot calculate a five
correctly let's say I move like this
black is comfortable I mean but how are
you going to win this
all its not like its widest falling
apart immediately and this is just very
strong because after a five black has a
very good news if you want to treat this
as a calculation exercise you can stop
supplamine oh and try to calculate as
many lines as as possible in this in
this position what didn't really have an
alternative to to this I mean black was
just threatening to to win the pawn yeah
II five what is a black supposed to play
now have a look okay playing the move
now Carlton took only five and what's
the point the point is after Bishop
takes which was played there's Quincy
six and now we see that what a water
battery here Bishop on b7 396 and as
mentioned this Bishop is blocking the
defense it seems that relatively
toughest defense now what we should
inform takes Andrew p3 simply
mechanically blocking the diagonal black
will win here without any doubt those
phones are too strong but this was
holding on for somewhat longer okay when
I understand that no human is going to
play this he play group g1 and now
Carson still needs to find some good
moves but he placed this absolutely
perfectly now from from f5 on I mean
even before I mean he was really wasn't
trouble about but starting here I think
he's playing absolutely technically
perfect game so it's really great oops I
screwed this up now Quincy six we were
here
why it's not working wait i press the
wrong button here no I have got it to
her right again so Quincy six yeah
threatening made you play group g1 to
cover and now Queen d5 you're all you
needed to see all this in at once
threatening this with mate and
threatening the bishop to double the
tech he needed to see this when he
played at five four months ago you
should take root cake so you get it back
and you still have this enormous
pressure we should reform and now
absolutely perfect play it's not super
difficult to spot but all in all I think
this is very impressive that he plays a
series of almost 15 or more perfect
moves h5 taking the bishop and this is
really very young visually pleasing the
bishop is detected where where should it
go cannot go anywhere here cannot go
here if it goes to oops he went here it
goes to e2 there's again this move just
have a look at this I did sir it's a
complete disaster we've got this thread
mate yeah Bishop t1 was played and this
is similar tis c3 Queen to f2 and now
look at five the invasion square is f to
look at five Queen takes or I need to
show this briefly sorry of course white
couldn't take because of this one
okay yeah it says it's even a fast horse
made with the bonds yeah and wins the
house also food so what cannot cannot
take a plate Queen F to look at five and
now queen yourself this is the point
rook f2 decides the game absolutely
nothing one can do G for Ruby five
strong white takes oops yeah and made
next move move the Queen Queen c7 and
now this threatens rookie to double
check mate and there's no defense and
karaoke in recent this is a force made
now and I think it's very impressive to
see how council I wanted this after
kayaking made this this King edge to as
as a as a mistake and then Bishop d4 and
it was absolutely merciless Howie Howie
punished this was really I'm really
amazing I am I had watched a bit of this
game on my mobile phone while i was at
the office today and I thought okay I
can't go in for 45 out of 5 and winning
this game even and then I saw how
quickly it went downhill and absolutely
perfect play then by my casa yeah he was
in trouble but he managed to win and
this means that kayaking still with a
great lead is 4 out of 5 is a brilliant
score but Carlton's now one point behind
and so is like a mirage it's also on +1
so maybe they are so some some chances
to to catch coyoacán but he still seems
to be in good form i don't think he
played him particularly bad game here he
just slipped up two times and and
got into trouble by M and M and the
trouble meant that cards needed to play
a play perfectly for for quite a long
sequence of moves yeah okay let's see
what what happens in this tournament
four rounds left and maybe higher can
even know yeah get some some decent
posture errs and this in this event yeah
thanks for watching hope you liked it